après l'interruption deuxième partie de
la voie est libre effectivement notre
débat des élections régionales sur
l'identité de la nouvelle région la
culture on en a déjà parlé et sur le
tourisme que nous avons entamé
précédemment avec nous jérôme durain
pour le ps brigitte monnet europe
ecologie les verts jérôme petit dans
alternative à gauche jean-philippe le
rêve lefebvre pour la liste allait rudy
jacques richard des ti front national et
charlery gallois pour l'upm
charles-henri gallois ou vous à
maltraiter tout à l'heure vous avez un
petit peu moins parler que les autres
c'est donc avec vous qu'on va reprendre
c'est ce débat on parlait du tourisme
tout à l'heure on a parlé de center
parcs vous parliez des référendums
locaux
un mot sur le tourisme tout de même on a
compris que la position de votre parti
est une position opposée à l'europe
on sait que sur le tourisme il ya des
aides européennes il ya des fonds il ya
des synergies européenne est ce que ça
vient en opposition avec ça pour vous
écouter pour nous sa vie à pain du tout
en opposition je fais comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure finalement les fonds
européens ne sont que de l'argent
français avec une fonction de 8
milliards au passage donc ça faut être
clair là-dessus après sur les atouts
touristiques de la région
je pense qu'on les a tous souligné on
est d'accord personne vallier ont incité
les les aoc et aop niveau du patrimoine
des sites extraordinaires et aussi vite
évidemment l'agriculture donc c'est osé
aubé et le tourisme viticole qui est
très important on a peut être les les
meilleurs vins du monde dans la région
vous parlez de chasseurs du jura
j'étais plus sur les ventes d'un jaune
du jura ne sont pas non plus eu
d'énormes départemental de l'upm est
très bien placé d'un bond de multiples
fautes de rien donc ne pourra pas dire
ce qu'il veut quand même sur l'idée par
exemple de travailler sur une marque
unique pourquoi ça existe déjà et nous
on est très clair là-dessus pour le coup
on va pas là seulement pour une franche
comté il n'existe pas non mais ça
existait un projet qui veulent être mis
en place et on le sait c'est sur la
table nous l'idée seconde je ne va pas
mentir aux citoyens on est contre cette
fusion des régions alors évidemment ça
se fait au niveau national
c'est pas au niveau régional qu'on va
changer ça mais pour nous cette réforme
territoriale elle est mauvaise on veut
revenir dessus puisque je l'expliqué
cette idée de grandes régions d'euros
région ça pouvait faire sourire certains
mais c'est l'idée du démantèlement de la
france au bout et nous on est clairement
contre ça on reviendra sur la fusion
burqa très fleurie personne c'est
simplement que là on est dans un débat
bourguignon franc comtois et qu'il faut
on en parle pas aux régionales on n'en
parle pas la présidentielle on entend le
poste européen n'en parle jamais parlé
d'une grande marque bourguignonne francs
franc comtoise vous qu'est ce que vous
en pensez jean-philippe à la fal même
façon que tout à l'heure je disais on a
créé une entité mais pas sa neuner ça ne
nie pas les deux identités
on a beaucoup parlé de nos tourisme on
vinifie pas le chardonnay de la même
façon en bourgogne et dans le jura et ça
donne pas du tout les mêmes goûts donc
je maintiens que on a deux identités et
donc sur le plan touristique on peut
très bien avoir deux marques celles de
la bourgogne et celle la franche comté
par contre on peut avoir une méthode
commune et on peut avoir des produits
communs sachant que la politique de la
région c'est celle de l'accompagnement
parfois de susciter mais c'est d'abord
de l'accompagnement la méthode s'est
créé une agence de l'attractivité
regroupant effectivement les comités
régionaux du tourisme mais également les
agences de développement parce que on
l'a dit le tourisme c'est d'abord de
l'économie et que une agence permettrait
aura sans doute une plus grande force de
frappe à l'extérieur parce que le
tourisme c'est d'abord du marketing
c'est vendre un territoire c'est nous
faire connaître à l'extérieur et donc là
encore ça c'est la méthode et puis il ya
effectivement je crois deux ou trois
produit si je puis dire qu'on peut
booster en tout cas qu'on souhaite
booster alors d'abord on à la véloroute
la véloroute 6 qui traverse la bourgogne
et la franche-comté vous savez les
nantais ont fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire sur l'estuaire à une
certaine époque avec jean blaise est
aujourd'hui notre projet c'est
d'accompagner cette véloroute peut-être
même d'en faire une heure une véloroute
d'intérêt régional
ce sera le cas des discussions des
conférences territoriales et afin
d'accompagner les collectivités qui
veulent terminer cette véloroute mais
aussi de d'en faire une sorte de dorsale
est ouest pour jeter un je termine de sa
salle pour que ce soit un élément très
forte d'attractivité et puis je termine
si j'en sache si les socialistes parlent
d'un pass unesco nous on pense qu'on
peut l'étendre non seulement au lieu
d'une et ce comme et aux maisons des
illustres au jardin remarquable qui a
posé sur un pass patrimoine patrimoine
culture plus vaste et au delà du socle
propos d'un pass unesco c'est aussi
l'idée de faire des bourguignons et des
franc comtois des ambassadeurs de leur
territoire et notamment ceux qui sont
énoncés par les hôteliers les
restaurateurs c'est quoi l'amour
alors je vais essayer d'être précis et
rapide et il s'agit pas d'un pass unesco
il s'agit d'un itinéraire spécifique qui
relie les six sites unesco et d'un pass
culturel bourgogne franche comté
qu'est ce qui se passe au niveau du
tourisme mondial d'ailleurs vu d'hong
kong
nous on est franc comtois nous on est
bourguignon ça marche pas c'est pour ça
qu'il faut avoir une marque beau gâchis
qu'est ce qui se faisait vous parler
s'il qu'est ce qui se passe quand on les
touristes internationaux ils veulent des
passes ils vont à new york qu'ils ont as
pas s'ils vont à rome ils sont
impassibles à paris son impasse
nous on a un pass pour la grande région
bourgogne franche comté
pardon je vais trop vite et du coup
c'est très important parce que ça
facilite la fac tivité du territoire
s'agissant du chanteur parc je veux y
revenir
il ne faut pas opposer les formes de
tourisme la démocratie existe la
démocratie existe il ya une commission
nationale du débat public le
si tout le monde peut s'y associer le
group center parcs rendra ses réponses
le 3 février et on voit bien que en
créant du tourisme familial chez sur
twitter par sacré aussi de
l'attractivité ça augmente le nombre de
nuitées sacré de l'activité locale ça
crée des emplois et ça crée des
débouchés pour nos produits chose car si
vous étiez une grande région ça ne tarde
pas qu'ils seraient allés faire deux
propositions dans deux régions
différentes caisses qui sont pas allés
jouer la subvention une époque où l'on
pense pas que ce sont donc une somme
unique y à deux fois 8 millions de
chacune des régions donc ça change pas
grand chose à l'économie du projet les
vraies questions du projet c est ce
qu'il ya un danger environnemental
oui non si c'est le cas nous n'y serons
pas favorable la commission des répondra
est ce qu'il ya un danger financier oui
ou non
et là encore on a mis des taquets on
n'ira pas à n'importe quelle condition
en revanche quand je vois que les trois
chambres consulaires de saône et loire
sont favorables que tout à populaire sur
lequel vous y est favorable
ça paraît important s'il vous plaît vous
pour vous payer quand même il ya le côté
il ya le côté financier il ya là
l'impact écologique mais y aller il ya
l'impact démocratique
à partir du moment où on n'a même pas
demander l'avis aux citoyens locaux et
même à l'ensemble de la région sur ce
sujet là je vois pas en quoi votre
tourisme il familiale il est il est je
suis obligé de vous les pêches les
empêcher de continuer parce que il est
12h 13 dans deux secondes 17 novembre
on s'était fixé pour vous permettre de
conclure que vous me regardez la
prochaine fois on fait deux heures ce
sera une piste pour nos prochains débats
régionaux ça prouve que ça prouve qu'il
ya des choses à discuter dans l'ordre en
conclusion on commence par vous jacques
richir des ti voilà donc on va revivre
nous revenons aux fondamentaux donc il
n'y a pas de quant au front national
parlera de culture qui nous parle de
culture il n'y a pas de peur à avoir y
aura pas de nuage de sauterelles qui
vous tombez ou sanctuary zh les 3% du
budget avec une préférence régionale je
le redis encore une fois où chaque euro
dépensé sera contrôlé vérifié
qu'est ce qu'il est devenu parce que là
aussi on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais on
avait tout un tas de communication
démentent dans tous les sens avec des
résultats que jamais été vérifiées
quantifier et analysés
un très très très très très important
voilà au niveau touristique évidemment
bien évidemment là c'est pareil nous
chaque euro chaque euro dépensé un
résultat pourquoi comment et par qui
l'union populaire républicaine alors je
vous ai dit lui père est un parti
relativement nouveau donc je vous donne
rendez-vous en 2017 pour l'élection
présidentielle avec monsieur françois
séguineau je vous invite à regarder nos
analyses sur le site ebay.fr et au
niveau régional nous sommes bel et bien
présent nous ferons une campagne de
proximité nous irons rencontrer les
citoyens une campagne encore une fois de
vérité comme je voulais dit noah pas
promettre monts et merveilles on va
d'abord analyser la situation va
expliquer aussi aux français aux
bourguignons franc comtois l'état de la
situation de la france et les problèmes
qui sont ici et donc voter upr c'est
voter quelque part pour un parti nouveau
qui n'a pas trempé dans les 40 dernières
années de marasme et qui hélas un parti
donné tu es encore une fois et de
proximité
nous vous invitons à voter pour nous le
6 décembre
jean philippe lefebvre pour la liste de
françois sauvadet
elle est rude et y si on est en
situation on proposera une politique
partagée une politique qui rende public
ses critères d'attribution
une politique qui fédère une politique
qui suscite une politique qui apaise et
moi je suis un homme de réformes et et
pas de révolution mais dix-huit mois
après notre arrivée aux affaires à dole
je pense que dans le domaine culturel
les gens sont rendus compte que la
réforme pouvait renverser et changer les
choses c'est exactement la même ambition
qu'on veut avoir au niveau régional je
précise juste pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas l'histoire locale sur le
bout des doigts l'histoire politique
donc que la ville de dole a basculé de
gauche à droite il ya 18 mois en mars
2014 les bourguignons groupe y voit là
ne suivaient pas forcément les
bourguignons suivaient pas forcément
giron petits dons c'est à vous de
conclure l'alternative à gauche
tel événement nous nous prenons donc
d'une politique culturelle le tourisme
également je pense que c'était être
hautement lié axée principalement sur
l'association des citoyens et des
acteurs dans ces domaines là nous devons
avoir une politique régionale en
concertation avec les citoyens et les
acteurs professionnels au niveau
régional il faut absolument que cette
politique ce ne soient pas simplement
une mise à disposition au public
il faut que la politique soit construite
ensemble vous faites tous des
conclusions encore plus courte que l'
enveloppe qu'on vous avait donné une
félicitation brigitte monnet à vous de
conclure pour la liste europe écologie
les verts alors moi pour conclure il ya
eu quelques citations lors de cette
table ronde j'ai envie de terminer avec
une cité une citation de nelson mandela
un grand homme qui disait que la culture
l arme la plus puissante qu'on puisse
utiliser pour changer le monde et avec
cécile prud'hommes avec les écologistes
nous avons envie de changer en tout cas
notre région en faire une région où il
fait bon vivre une région qui soit
respectueuse des hommes et des femmes
qui vivent qui travaillent qui prennent
des loisirs aussi une région
respectueuse de son environnement et je
voulais quand même dire à mon collègue
de go ce que vous savez à la fin de
l'année il ya une grande une grande
conférence internationale sur le climat
et le but c'est de limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 2 degrés est
ce que vous pensez qu'avec deux bulles
sur la grande région bourgogne franche
comté chauffée à 29 degrés toute l'année
on réussira à tenir cet engagement et
sans vous avez largement dépassé la
durée de la compliance and the wind
jambes dures à court terme alors 45
secondes c'est très court effectivement
la grande région qui nous a été présenté
les parfois angoissantes le fn l'epr ou
très contrainte pour notre collègue de
l'upper moi je crois qu'il faut avoir
envie de céder en région il faut avoir
une envie de dynamique nous avec
marie-guite dufay ont un projet qui qui
est contenu dans ce document un travail
collaboratif qui a été fait avec
l'ensemble des citoyens de la grande
région
c'est un projet de transformation
écologique économique sociale solidaire
citoyens de cette grande région et je
crois qu'il faut plutôt envisager
l'avenir cette grande région de façon
rayonnante de vouloir conforter les
solidarités le développement économique
des projets des services pour tous les
citoyens
merci à tous les six d'avoir joué le jeu
je connais des débats qui vont alors la
rue en un mot sur cette série de débats
va là vient de passer du tourisme et la
culture aujourd'hui hélas spectacle
premier c'était le premier aujourd'hui
donc le prochain samedi prochain on va
parler mobilité transports et il sera
question également de l'aéroport de dole
tavaux
à ce moment là parce que vous n'en avez
pas parler les uns et les autres voilà
le on avait préparé nos fiches aussi là
dessus après nous parlerons dans quinze
jours du développement économique et de
l'information c'est le gros morceau si
j'ose dire des compétences d'un conseil
régional qu'il soit petit ou grand comme
bourgogne franche comté et puis le
dernier thème sera consacré donc à
l'agriculture et à l'environnement
et puis bien sûr on commence un journal
des élections et le lundi 23 nov
ce sera juste deux semaines j'étudie
deux semaines avant le premier tour
c'est parfait la politique bien sûr dans
vos journaux régionaux sur le site
internet et dans nos deux blogs
politiques en bourgogne et en
franche-comté parce qu'il ya plein de
petites histoires racontées aussi
merci à tous les six merci vous de
savoir si inaugurer cette série bon
week-end au revoir
on
non
une